and we are back live at the National
Book Festival on the mall in Washington
DC we'll be here for a couple more hours
we now are going to be doing a call-in
program with historian Michael Beschloss
thank you for standing out here in the
field and the Hazara with us a little
bit if I begin to sneeze and gag it's
not you it's a people well mister best
loss we were just listening to James
Swanson author of manhunt can you write
a book about presidential courage and
brave leaders without including Abraham
Lincoln well I come from Illinois so I
think if I did not go back home people
would not like it too much but Lincoln
is really sort of one of the cardinal
examples at least in the story I tell
because in 1864 Lincoln was told the way
you can get reelected is get off the
Emancipation Proclamation if you don't
do it you won't it was pretty stark and
he actually toyed with it for a moment
but realized that it would be impossible
he essentially said for me to do this
and still be what I think of is Abraham
Lincoln did the right thing thank God
for us all not a man to be forced to
Andrew Jackson Andrew Jackson a very
tough guy came to office in 1829 and if
you went to see Andrew Jackson in his
bedroom as he often times had a visiting
senator come to see him there his health
was not always that great he would
sometimes point to a gun was mounted on
the wall they see that gun I used it to
kill someone who insulted my wife to
sort of focus the mind and remind them
that he did not get rolled too easily
and Jackson when he came to office he
has been elected as the basically the
Prince of the common people is he called
the first non aristocrat to be President
and he was very serious about something
called the Bank of the United States in
Philadelphia had enormous power
and we can't even imagine nowadays they
had bribed lots of members of Congress
and members of the press and so on
Jackson was resolved either Reformatory
lit in the Enfield he had to kill it and
by doing that he knew that it had also
add except Iranian power he had to
assume that the bank might destroy him
and was essentially at that death battle
he wound up conquering with the bank it
was gone from the scene
Americans liberties were no longer
endangered but he took a big risk in
doing so once again we're glad he's in
place most of us did you add what
qualities did you look for when you were
writing this book mainly character you
know if someone is obsessed with being
popular and holding on to the presidency
and almost any cost I'm saying that no
not only in history but also as we're
looking at presidential candidates this
year and next that person is not someone
you should vote for because the
tradition that I write about that I
think George Washington began and I tell
the story of presidential courage says
that when there's a big issue like Civil
War World War two equal rights rich
versus poor we Americans demand and have
a right to expect that a president may
make a decision and so unpopular that he
or she might lose their reelection or
their popularity or even their life
that's what we expect so I think when
you're looking at someone who might be
present say is this someone would be
likely to do that I think I read
correctly that you write that a
president tend not to risk re-election
am I correct about that I think they
tend not to accept or is it if it is on
a cardinal issue even Abraham Lincoln I
come from Illinois
they call Americans at least most of us
think pretty well of Lincoln and
Illinois even more so you know when
Lincoln was told you know give up or at
least distance yourself from the
Emancipation Proclamation to get
reelected Lincoln did not immediately do
the right thing we thought well be a
disaster if I lose McClellan my opponent
would be a terrible president the
country would splinter which he probably
would have and he began to rationalize
you know what maybe my election really
is so essential that I should somehow
find lawyers language to suggest I
didn't really believe in the
Emancipation or I'm looking at it a lot
more narrowly and finally one of the
things that decided it for it was he
began to think of language he might use
and he called in Frederick Douglass and
we knew pretty well said you know how
would you accept language like this and
Douglass is angry you know sulfurous
angry furious face told him everything
he needed to know which was you know I
can't do this I can't do something so
cheap so in the end he did do the right
thing and was able to survive in your
view has president george w bush own
presidential courage well the thing i
say in the book is you know there's a
difference between history and current
events a lot of people do current events
really well it's not what I do in life
what history is is when you wait 30 or
40 years and get information that you
didn't have at a time that the president
serving and also hindsight you can see
how the story turned out more or less
what was important what was not
important
so thirty years from now at least in my
view that's the only time in a story and
we'll be able to have a solid judgment
but I think we could begin to ask some
of the questions that his historian
might ask which would be part of the war
on terrorism turnout certainly how did
the war in Iraq turn out a few others
and history sometimes provide some
surprises when you wait that long
sometimes it doesn't
let's take some calls and numbers are on
the screen 202 is the area code 737
triple zero one if you are a Republican
737 triple zero to four Democrats and
all others six to eight 0 to 0-5 Queens
New York you're first up for microfiche
lines
I think much for taking my call Michael
um I want to actually about two people
that I find very fascinating one that
was actually is the President Jimmy
Carter and the other is actually a Vice
President Gore who you know I didn't win
but when it comes Estes
I know Jimmy Carter is the writers for a
lot of things during his sermon you know
the forces from state steps to AT&T work
or 70s music um but you know I think
Jimmy Carter's face down a lot of
negative things as the economic crisis
and the crisis into the belief in the
Camp David Accords and that same reasons
that kind of a thing so what are you
thoughts about Jimmy Carter's courage
and bravery in office contrary to what
many people think is his weakness and
also for Allen for what do you think his
president president he would have
entailed in terms of courage and bravery
and fading down for example 9/11 or war
or another economic crisis during the
flat eight years thank you so much thank
you sir
Jimmy Carter I think showed guts on two
particular cases one was 1977 the Panama
Canal treaties many Americans don't even
remember this anymore but that was a
time when he felt that there needed to
be these treaties ratified to return the
canal to Panama or least to get the
canal to Panama
the hounds of hell descended on Carter
as a result it was the first time that a
big opposition basically went after
Carter many of the same people who
caused his defeat for reelection in 1980
and there was virtually no upside for
Carter there wasn't a big constituency
saying we just love that Panama Canal 3
huge downside he did it anyway but I
think also as you look at the way that
Carter handled the hostage crisis the
Iran hostage crisis 1980 you can
criticize a lot of the things that
happened during that period but one
decision he made I think is of the order
of the kind of things I'm talking about
he knew that in the last 7 or 10 days
before that election 1980 against Ronald
Reagan had he done some kind of an
attack on Tehran even if it had killed
some American service former aliens that
probably would have improved his poll
numbers and some political consultants
were suggesting that he do that and what
Carter proved was wanted to be reelected
but there were certain things he wanted
more and in that case I think he did the
right thing so I think he does deserve
honor thank you for the call Al Gore in
9/11 Al Gore and 9/11 what he might have
done I tend to sort of shy away from
predicting what someone might have done
in a certain situation so that is
something that I think the caller will
feel unsatisfied and will just never
know New Albany Mississippi you're on
with Michael Beschloss yes mr. Beschloss
is a pleasure to talk to you thanks I
was just in Columbus Mississippi
yesterday I saw I had we given the
speech if I may ask yes Mississippi
University for women which is a great
place as I'm sure you know yes I yes it
is I was I would like that who of course
question sir excuse my speech that I am
suffered suffered a stroke you're doing
harm alright if I don't make myself
clean please please make it clear to me
hours ago I was how I would like to ask
you um as a presidential historian
you believe that up research into the
tournament administration of George Bush
will be hampered by his and tetanus
tendency to have things secret and and
not available to to through scholars in
the media there is a long term problem
that's getting worse all the time and
that is that presidents are encouraged
by the people around them not to leave a
paper trail I mean this didn't start
with george w bush but the tradition may
be accelerating now I mean in recent
years one of the first things that a
White House lawyer says to a new
president when he comes into office is
no certainly don't send emails try not
to keep Diaries try not to send letters
don't put too much in memos because you
know there may be a scandal these things
might be subpoenaed by a prosecutor me
and George Bush the Elders diaries were
actually revealed in the iran-contra
contra investigation even while he was
president and the other thing is of
course these things could get leaked and
I can understand why a self-protective
president the people around it might
want to do that but this is hell for us
historians because for instance to write
this book going all the way back to
George Washington I've used these
wonderful letters that for instance John
Adams and his wife wrote to each other
and Diaries all sorts of sources
national security documents all the way
up through the time of the 1980's those
kind of sources are being made less and
less partly because presidents don't
want to keep the paper trail and the
other problem is all of our full I don't
know about you but I don't write
terribly many letters anymore which I
really pour my heart out my wife
complains about this
I send her emails but they're not
exactly equivalent and so the result is
that you don't have something like John
Adams telling what's really on his mind
for instance one exchange of letters I
quote in this book is that when John
Adams was about to do something that was
very controversial and dangerous and
actually wound up costing in the
presidency he wrote to his wife who was
up in Massachusetts and said potentially
what do you think and she replied by
letter she said I have revolved the
subject on my pillow
I think you've committed a masterstroke
a wonderful letter gives you a sense of
who Adams really was Eleanor Roosevelt
wrote to a friend about her marriage I
quote from this in the mid-thirties
tells you almost everything one sentence
she wrote more and more I feel that
Franklin her husband is a great man
and he's nice to me but he treats me
like a stranger there's almost nothing
more you need to know to give you at
least a sense of the complexities in
that marriage these are the kind of
sources that are disappearing making it
very hard for us historians are right
about presidents to really get into
their brains we talked with Laura Bush
yesterday and asked her if she'd be
writing a book about her years in the
White House she demurred do you expect a
book by George W Bush within a year they
often do but his father didn't for
instance didn't want to write a memoir
and finally wrote a book I'm sure you
remember with Brent Scowcroft that came
out in the late 1990s it was on the end
of the Cold War and they actually got
along pretty well but there were some
things that they didn't actually say in
their own voices who couldn't find a
common voice so you read the book it
almost looks like a play it has
Scowcroft : his comment about something
then Bush : his comment I do know from
the elder Bush that he did not enjoy the
experience at all so
what kind of advice is given asana do
you find value in those books you do in
presidential memoirs you find what they
found important but in general
presidential memoirs are usually not
very good and not very revealing Lyndon
Johnson who was at least nine runs with
Johnson tapes I don't need to tell you
how interesting he was in private and
the wonderful put in quote languages I
cannot repeat here he used he wrote a
book that made him say more boring than
Calvin Coolidge he didn't want to seem
like a backwoods but he said he wanted
to look like a president
unfortunately Johnson's idea the
president was Grover Cleveland and if
you read that book you wouldn't have any
idea that he was any more controversial
so oftentimes a memoir is not the best
revelation on a prison so Buffalo thanks
for holding you're on with Michael
Beschloss on book TV good afternoon and
Michael thank you you're going to dr.
when I just thought against your mayor
Grover Cleveland I'm Paula Zahn
that's all right thank you for your work
and thanks the c-span I am remind nearly
everybody I talked to after reading
about Washington's second term and
visiting Springfield Ohio in the hall
where they put up what people said about
them I say here's a correlation you
should remember that the greatness of a
president is usually inversely related
to the contemporary assessment of his
opposition and the press and I think you
said something very similar to that but
I condense it to a a Jesuit style
corollary so thank you for your work and
I think it's something we all should
remember about people who stand up in
the face of all sorts of opposition and
stick with their guns and if they were
wrong they were wrong but if they were
right then they become great at history
I think that's nicely Senen is often the
case
and the opposite is also true you know
presidents who are oftentimes hugely
praised turn out to be praised in their
time because they like being popular
were good according that Warren Harding
when he died in 1923 was one of died one
of the most popular and lamented
American presidents in history mainly
because he thought that his job was to
do what people wanted you know stay
aloof from the world you know don't do
much to have the government regulate the
economy and with the great depression of
the rise of Hitler
they weren't due to hardly not do too
much but they certainly were not helped
for James Buchanan who preceded Abraham
Lincoln was someone who just felt that
he didn't want to engage the issue of
slavery and try to avert the Civil War
and the result was civil war when it
happened was bloodier and more violent
more dangerous than had you can enact
Arlington Washington go ahead with your
comment yes good afternoon
appreciate the opportunity I'd like to
dr. Beschloss I'd like to go back to one
of your earlier books Mayday huh and Wow
and in the context of the recent opening
of the Soviet and Russian archives and
the publication of the I consider a
seminal book Khrushchev's cold war inter
you've read it I'm wondering if there
would be any reassessment and your
conclusions in Mayday and also in
connection with subsequent events in
Vietnam and Nixon and Kissinger trying
to extricate us while at the same time
maintain provision of leadership for
America and the world Amina thank you
yeah on Eisenhower the end of the Cold
War that one it was your kinda mentioned
I wrote it when I was I think about
twenty-nine
1986 that was on how Eisenhower got
embroiled in the u2 affair this spy
plane we sent over the Soviet Union it
came down and caused a big international
incident
and I felt that this was a chance that
America and Russia had to reduce the
harshness of the Cold War that basically
didn't happen because of this accident
that caused a lot of misunderstandings
and also genuine fears and anger to
spiral out of control and as a result we
had some of the worst in most dangerous
years of the Cold War in the early 60s
and that's one I'm not I hope a very
self-congratulatory person and if you're
a historian you always have to be
disciplined by new information and
thinking that you may have gotten it
will own but that's one one happy that
most of the information that's come out
of the Saudi brooding would suggest that
that probably was not Roland thank you
for mentioning mr. Beschloss how many
books have you written I think nine the
c-span has been doing the presidential
libraries indeed I'll call Eisenhower
last night with Richard Norton spear is
wonderful now and we've been digging
into the libraries were meditating to
the archives
with the new trend towards more secrecy
our is the Clinton Library less
accessible and perhaps the W library
going to be less accessible Italy
currently are it's hard to predict in
terms of the Clinton Library
my sense is in fact I'm going to see it
in November for the first time it's not
terribly different from recent libraries
in terms of terms of the speed opening
but I think one thing that people are
sensitive to and this was true of our
earlier caller and that is that if you
ever have a former president that takes
measures to try to keep the papers open
up close too long to try to help his own
career that's going to hurt him with the
American people and it really will with
historians because it may shock some
viewers the way historians of people too
and if we're walking into a Presidential
Library and it becomes pretty clear to
us quickly that the president of the
people trying to protect it in other
words the formal one former president
people trying to protect him or trying
to keep things closed to try to improve
his resident reputation we've story ins
are going to naturally react by saying
well what what must he be hiding there
must be something there he must have a
lot to apologize for so if you look at
something the opposite like Dwight
Eisenhower will basically said open the
stuff as quickly and as widely as
possible that tends on balanced and
healthy Minneapolis you're on the air
yeah what were you doing I want a thing
I want to thank Michael so much for his
book I just want to add in one question
all right I will write a story about it
later
between a current event and history
could you repeat that it didn't quite
come through
in all agree that you want to write
about that you so dearly love haze on
leadership and then you want to between
correlated bank and history how do you
go about caller one more time could you
just simplify it give us a keyboard on a
little bit of a high level here it's not
you you want to write about a leader or
you want to write between current event
and history of a leader that has served
long ago it could be Adam Jonathan it
would be another good leader that serve
long ago that you want to be let be
trained to write on called not query
design our history but to write in the
program provisional reason yeah yeah
yeah I agree with you that's the reason
why this book is and I just published
you were nice enough to show ends in
1989 because I think you can't write
about anything more recent and have it
be real history because you don't have a
big portion of the information that a
historian really needs to get into a
president's head and you also have not
had enough time past to really see how
things worked out and see events not as
current events invest in politics but
really his history thank you for the
call and I hope we heard it right
Wilmington Delaware you're on with
Michael Beschloss book TV
how are you mr. bachelor very well I
have a question about there's a certain
cable news channel that had sort of
adapted FDR for themself and they're
getting him wrong and I'm gonna do it
well they're just blatantly wrong about
you know censorship and stuff like that
and take the day or two for it to come
out but you know can you give us a
specific example of what your referral
yeah I think I think it was Bill
O'Reilly that that FDR censored World
War two
and I and I knew you know in the
beginning were you know Pearl Harbor and
stuff but then he wanted to get the
violence out so I mean don't you think
well let me comment I haven't heard what
Bill O'Reilly said let me talk about
Roosevelt a little bit
Roosevelt if he were here today I think
he'd be the first to say I had to make
some tough choices in 1940 in 1941
you know I was dealing with the
possibility that the United States might
have to deal with that all Hitler we
thought there were German spies so he
did a number of things that don't stand
up very well in history perhaps most
monumentally the internment of
japanese-americans in 1942 which is a
big shadow and should be on Franklin
Roosevelt's reputation the problem even
if Roosevelt was were to say that was
necessary you know ends versus means I
had to do everything I could to resist
the Japanese and Hitler World War with
us the problem there is is that later
presidents like for instance a Lyndon
Johnson or Richard Nixon will say as
they did well I'm a war president too
Nixon would say Roosevelt knocked his
opponents abused the FBI used the IRS or
its earlier equivalent and so they're
therefore so should I so when you get
into the area of the president who
begins to do things that may flirt with
even violating the laws some of them TRS
actions might be construed you can argue
that it may be necessary at the time and
even that one I'm not sure both a lot of
water but the long-term problem is it's
a slippery slope because you may be
licensing later President Theodore
Roosevelt's courageous president I think
he was and he's in this book and the
reason I put it in is that when TR
became president in 1901 he was a
president by accident his predecessor
William McKinley had to murdered he
really wanted to get elected in his own
right so he wouldn't feel as if he only
been able to make it by assassination
despite that he went totally against the
establishment of his party the
Republican Party by saying I'm against
these trusts I think they got too much
power big business has too much power in
American life and I think it should be
regulated @tr just one to win reelection
it the last thing he would have done and
for at least a period of time he
endangered his chance to be nominated
again in the end of course he was
Richmond Virginia I had the best lot I
appreciate all your life thank you Peter
of your commentaries on the Lyndon
Johnson tapes all we saw it helped me
understand at the council is one of the
world's most complex that you spot you
interesting pebbles complex I get to do
adjustments as you know yeah probably
that and contradictory says excluded if
you can tell a couple of LBJ my panic
Destin sort of revealed housing
difficult questions could be one what a
complex person Johnson could see I'll
give you one since we're short on time
Johnson as you know I think he did great
things above all civil rights Medicare
through the things he did especially in
64 and 65 but also at the time this was
a president who was beginning the
Vietnam War big American involvement and
at the same time as he was sending the
first hundred thousand troops to Vietnam
in the early months of 1965 he would
meet with them in public and say I want
you to win the war we always win the
wars we fight I want your mail the
Coonskin on the wall we'll do whatever
we can to help you
I heard tapes and perhaps you've heard
them too where he's talking to his
defense secretary Robert McNamara and
saying things like I can't think of
anything worse than losing the war in
Vietnam and I do not see any way that we
can win
and you know to begin to use the word
complexity to talk about this for two
hours
a president who at the same time as he's
sending people into harm's way saying
we're going to win in private saying at
the beginning of the war I don't think
there's a chance it's something that is
not exactly the best side of Lyndon
Johnson's character as many good things
as you really did we have about five
seven minutes left with our guests
Michael Beschloss the wind has now died
it is hot the two of us began to melt
were not in Madame Tussauds it's a exim
what are the best sources for you for
finding suspended material about the
presidency and getting beyond the press
relations and the biggest thing is if
you hear basically his own voice or
other voices in real time for instance
if a president kept an honest Diary
Harry Truman kept a diary it was
probably too honest and then I found all
these pans i semitic things he was
saying at the same time he's actually
doing good things like recognizing the
state of israel that were helpful with
the jewish people but you begin to get a
window on his soul how contradictory he
really was in many ways or when a
president writes to someone that he
trusts and those very well Dwight
Eisenhower who was not exactly a
touchy-feely person who you know
essentially said what he was really
feeling at a high school classmate when
he wrote - until the classmate died the
1950s for page after page gives you a
window on Eisenhower but look at the two
that I've mentioned diaries letters
those are two of these examples that
present fathers that don't really keep
him
so one thing historians are going to
have to do is push presidents hard push
the people around them very hard to in
some way keep a contemporaneous record
the cat make tapes anymore like the
Lyndon Johnson tapes because people
rightfully say great historical source
you know wonderfully captivating
listened to but horrible invasion of
civil liberties to take people without
their knowledge someone a few years ago
suggested that maybe you put a
department store type surveillance
camera and the Oval Office and tape
everything and only release it after
fifty or seventy-five years would be
great for us scholars my guess is a
program next call comes from Georgia
Georgia you're on the air with Michael
Beschloss gentlemen good day producer my
question concerns Abraham Lincoln Mary
and I'm in Georgia deep in South Georgia
Alma Georgia whimpers thank you so much
mr. Lincoln understand that Lincoln
arrested hundreds perhaps thousands of
political enemies shut down opposition
newspapers and suspended habeas corpus
during the War Between the States as
well as making many clear statements
that the white race is more superior to
the black race these sound to son like
the actions of a racist dictator but my
question is is the myth of Lincoln
I don't think it is and I think you were
talking you were talking to Doug Wilson
earlier about Abraham Lincoln and
Douglas Wilson who will wrote Lincoln
sword which is the book that you were
talking about he spoke about today is
magnificent times and there have been
some people in recent times writing not
about Lincoln I think you have to look
at a little bit more in the context of
his time in which he looks a lot better
and of course ultimately in terms of is
this someone who saw the evils of
slavery won the Civil War and made sure
that slavery at the end would be
abolished but he was in no way of saying
in one of the ways as you rightly say he
was not a saint was big infringement of
civil liberties that led some later
wartime presidents to say Abraham
Lincoln did it I can do it too thank you
sir
last call from Michael Beschloss in
Lexington Kentucky
yes dr. Beck gosh this is really Lincoln
Day you're I assume near the toddfamily
home
yes well I've actually worked as a toast
there later here at the very title good
good good but my question was concerning
who to book taking charge and reaching
for glory huh
and have you are you planning to write a
third book finishing up Johnson's
presidency because I really enjoy those
first in fact you talk about the taking
or a comment that he made I think was it
taken charge about the way to win in
Vietnam
right like that now that was actually
the second one reason reaching for glory
but I'm going to do that that the tapes
have opened a little bit more slowly
they're supposed to be finished being
open in the next year or two and looking
forward very much although my wife
always tells me that when I'm listening
to those tapes a lot listening to LBJ
the quality and repeatability of my
language gets worse and worse so I'll
try to resist that thank you for calling
sir Michael Beschloss has been our guest
here on book TV at the National Book
Festival this is his most recent book
presidential courage brave leaders and
how they changed America 1789 to 1989 Mr
Beschloss what's your next book haven't
decided yet if you've got an idea before
for I'd be very grateful
thank you for being willing to join and
in fact we covered Michael Beschloss
talk in the history and biography 10:00
here at the National Book Festival that
will air later on on book TV so you'll
be able to see that later on his
presentation and with an audience and in
fact this whole program that you've been
watching today re airs tonight beginning
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time you'll be able
to see the whole thing starting with the
Laura Bush interview everything we've
done today
we haven't made too many mistakes so I
don't think we'll do too much editing
yet who said knock wood we're not done
for the day
Tom Aldridge has been in charge of all
of this coverage that we've been doing
today
there's some other events that we are
taping and not being able to show you
live and you will see throughout the
weekend on VOC TV including Michael Oren
on America in the Middle East we've got
two things down at the veterans tent
very interesting one is on the world war
two